[Music]
we love drama don't we know we should
call this JK drama moon let's do it
imagine alright you found out you
married a simp you had no [ __ ] idea
true true simpler just like a true a
trees that means you're assemble
yourself okay it's like I found out I
made a girl simp
alright guys soon nobody tell Casey what
a simple we'll play that game yes
Gio is on nice all right check this out
hi Steve what's a sim I've never seen a
space twinkle like that boy hey Z I will
literally go to my grave never telling
you what synthesis I'm gonna have to
you're gonna have to open dictionary
this later everyone else join in don't
talk nobody tell Casey don't even go to
macalmon nobody alright there's a lot of
material guys so I thirty two female
found out last night that my husband 37
male stalked and manipulated me into a
relationship sounds like true love oh
yeah stems are very bad all of my
relationships it's like they you show
and Netflix yeah so she met her hot
husband Dave okay about five years ago
they've been married for about two and a
half years now they have adorable two
months old twenty old month 20 or 20
month and she's four months pregnant
with another okay they just bought a
house a couple years ago all right there
they live in the suburbs very
picture-perfect dave was an acquaintance
of a co-worker about five years ago I
started to see him frequently at the bar
we go to get drinks after work I admit
that at first I wasn't particularly
attracted to him now not that he's ugly
he just wasn't the type I was into at
that point in my life anyways when Dave
started coming around he would rather he
would after a while try to chitchat with
me it was obvious he was interested but
I try to decline his advances as gently
as I could he was persistent and one
night after maybe one drink too many I
agreed to go out on a date with him I
remember the date started out a bit
quert as our previous encounters had
always been within a group so it was the
first time it was just a two of us plus
I admit I didn't really want to be here
he considered cancelling but I was
having a really bad luck dating hearts
her bad so I decided that since I had no
other plans why not anyway the day
started out slow and it was mostly Dave
talking for the first half but then
after a while you started bringing up
some topics that I was interested in
okay a hobby a particular cause which I
felt strongly about he's innocent how he
knew the second half of the date was
much better and I was kind of surprised
to learn that Dave and I actually had
some things in common I was still
hesitant but decided to give Dave a
chance although he definitely liked me a
lot more than I liked him in the
beginning our relationship slowly began
to grow and eventually I fell in love
with them since then I would say that we
had a really good relationship he's my
best friend an excellent father and a
great husband furthermore he was a great
provider as well once our daughter that
had made the most financial sense for me
to quit my job stay home it was a role
that I admitted was not a hundred
percent on board with in the beginning
but when we looked at the numbers he was
just the most logical decision despite
my initial hesitancy I have since grown
to love it I honestly couldn't imagine
having to spend so much time away from
my daughter but I recognized that
because of my husband we are in a very
fortunate position to do so that's like
it's all good so far where's that right
okay so I don't forgot a rare couple
flight she's like everything's too good
we're gonna [ __ ] it up
the issue like many people my husband
has been working at home since the whole
coronavirus mess started it looked a
little bit of took a little adjustment
but it hasn't been too bad as my husband
works in IT his work hasn't been
disrupted too much by having to work
remotely I think in change of
environment Balaban holy [ __ ] with the
star sign while you're at I know right
you still connected my husband has been
meeting virtually once or twice a week
with friends or coworkers last night he
was playing games with his little
brother Tom oh my god was the [ __ ]
issue shirt and he was wearing my
favorite shoes you know those shoes that
I saw at Marshall's I think he got him
there what do you think oh [ __ ] wait
you're not just using em for our
anniversary I noticed he was drinking
playing games with his friends okay a
little more than usual after she puts
her daughter to bed she checked herself
went to see if she had a message from
Tom's girlfriend the brother his friend
his friend his friend he's so he's
playing games with his little brother
Tom right so he checked if Tom's
girlfriend got a message right they've
been dating for about a year and a half
now and since they only live about an
hour away holy [ __ ] I'm frequently
double-date
okay digressing so much I know I do this
this is so much [ __ ] information and
I can't Bowl appoint it because I don't
know where the pregnant tell stories
like this yeah whole time I'm like get
to the point so I was super excited when
I opened up the message and officially
engage it was a good [ __ ] trap a [ __ ]
you [ __ ] we're
we're talking about bumper cars this
episode is about bumper car I miss the
exhilaration of being in a bumper car as
another bumper car slams into my bumper
that's right man I want to [ __ ] give
up on this dude I
this [ __ ] wrote a [ __ ] novel and
still hasn't gotten to this after the
beep ok so just the title alone it
already kind of like I'm like a [ __ ]
egg in this your computer
let me try find it litter no no you're
not gonna find it you won't find it bro
it's girls right when she put it in bald
where the [ __ ] problem is she's like
in I had to take a [ __ ] it was about as
approximately 14 centimeters long extra
bigger than usual yes I have a friend
like this where this has been an issue
for him way he'll tell you a story if
it's on the phone multiple people
including myself have fallen asleep on
him while he's telling the story and I
think it comes to the point where he
just goes yeah I get it people hopefully
poor buddy or maybe maybe you complain
about how you can't fall asleep at night
and he's your favorite maybe that's it
maybe I should be more appreciative you
know my head tell me about you know
listen to the stories until I fall
asleep it's like one of those that the
combat where there's good who tried it
they're pretty good yeah is he really
smart I'm not gonna say yes or no mommy
you just said yes or no huh you don't
know who your friend is it's not this
one does he on JK news is he in this
room is he right here is he right there
is that your friend his little brother
right he just got engaged so she was
checking the text because he was talking
to Tom he got engaged and he was like
thanks Big Dave if it wasn't for you in
your advice I wouldn't be where I am
today she's like what's his advice
exactly and it took me three [ __ ]
paragraphs to get that bullet point Wow
let me get back into this
rollercoasters you know the number when
I miss I miss Riddler's revenge where's
the magic Mountain no solar water shut
down right now I can't go you mean like
yo Six Flags is dope because we went
like a few months before this Hope 14
and nobody's there here is the real
story alright this is juicy I promise
you okay alright so she went downstairs
and she was like so what did you tell
him what was the advice she she knows us
much so far though but does she check
his phone
no no cuz they're all friends and then
so Tom's girlfriend messaged her you
know so she was like oh you guys got
engaged yeah and everyone's celebrating
and he's like thanks Big Dave you gave
me advice so she's like what was that
advice well what did you do to like you
know get me right so apparently Dave saw
his wife the wife that's writing this on
a dating site about a half a year before
they even met apparently he started
creating a bunch of fake profiles oh
[ __ ] he stole pictures of attractive men
from different social media profiles
basically catfishing the [ __ ] using
these profiles he started basically yeah
catfishing her over the course of a
couple months he was able to get
conversations numerous occasions of
different things information and then he
spent hours searching through Facebook
LinkedIn before he found her picture
then he really started stalking her
online with different profiles and
friends and all that stuff so after a
couple of months he started stalking her
in real life not just online then he
started going to hang out at bars they
went to after work and he befriended her
co-worker Mark that's not this sim this
is the best [ __ ] port why did it take
her an eternity I almost [ __ ] ran
away that's that's a psychopath so mark
worked in IT like Dave and even though
he was nice he was socially awkward and
a bit of a loner so he was easy to
become friends with anyways Dave started
talking to Mike stalking Mike and
becoming his friend to meet her I don't
know I find them still in this story
mentally I'm trying to catch up so he he
he confessed all of this to her yeah
well you confused on what happened maybe
wait so yeah it catch me up basically
let me outline this for everybody out
there that's like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] talking about right so she found
out that her husband was basically
manipulating the whole situation it
wasn't authentic the way he did it was
he planned this from six months ago when
he first saw her beautiful picture on a
dating site right created several
accounts catfished her got all this
information and data so he started to
know about her
and so when he actually got on the date
with her he could relay with all these
things oh you like that I like that
perfect date right it's like there you
show it is that you can t even
befriended mark to get into her circle
cuz he stalked her online found out
where he she word all this stuff where
they would hang out and like what bars
they went to I'd be flattered really
I mean let's look at the better side she
has a great child I know but the only
thing with this creepy though say by
side he did to the extreme of like first
stalking here doing a lot of stuff and
then becoming friends with some of those
friends with her well that's how every
guy and girl does it like if they like
someone they go and find the interest on
facebook on creepy when you say it out
loud right yeah yeah but guys do this
guys and girls do this and then they
start taking all of this girl likes EDM
I almost on this in that EDM I don't
like EDM but I know she does and maybe
she will like me because of that and
then maybe in three years in a but you
know I don't like EDM I think the crazy
part is he stimulated a whole bunch of
different versions of the conversations
and he played out that scenario so many
times too by the time he met in person
she knew exactly what to say a
probability game because he was like
well she could only be dating so many
people at once
so if I create a relationship with her
with 10 other guys I'm eventually gonna
get her and receiving a guy that she was
dating at the moment that Dave paid what
it's crazier and crazier but
unfortunately we ran out of time and
this [ __ ] wasted [ __ ] paint minutes
of this [ __ ] [ __ ] explaining his hair
was blue and
that day I was driving a Prius now you
know what guess what [ __ ] you for
[ __ ] riding like that I wouldn't wear
I didn't wear cotton panties because it
kind of itch a little bit so I was
wearing lycra you're like a goddamn yelp
review or stop so we were mad at her him
her uh her her she's the [ __ ] don't
care you're an [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]